I think on the Chinese side there is a
skepticism that the United States will
accept the rise of China to a kind of
co-equal status you know I think it's
just kind of common sense that that you
wouldn't want to see another country
emerges that as the sole superpower but
I you know from an economic point of
view there's no reason for Americans to
fear china rising to a similar economic
statuses the United States I think in
China there's a lot of skepticism that
the American people and the American
government will accept this on the
American side I think there's a lack of
understanding that that on the economic
side you know China now really is a
capitalist system with a tremendous
amount of economic freedom and this has
generated a lot of prosperity it's
produced a middle class and you know
Chinese people are pretty happy with
this system so i do think on the
economic side there's a lot of potential
for the countries to cooperate
harmoniously and I think I me so I think
on the American side there's a little
bit of a little bit of a
misunderstanding about the extent to
which China's reform partly because
Americans tend to equate capitalism with
democracy and personally I think in the
long run there's a pretty close
relationship between capitalism and
democracy but the long run is pretty
long and over 20 30 years I think you
can develop a pretty well functioning
capitalist system under a one-party
system and I'm not sure Americans fully
appreciate that
you